i am able to speak a complex language  with many thousands of words  because i've found other ways to learn  vocabulary quicker i've used mnemonics  you know so for instance with french you  come across a word for train station  like  and you think okay it sounds like garg  or  garfield i'll imagine garfield the cat  is  running through a train station to catch  a train to the lasagna eating  competition of the world because a lot  of people will say  i can kind of read the language when i  see it on paper i'll see a word  and i know what that means but when i  have to produce it then i can't i don't  know how to say it  and the great thing about mnemonics is  that it is symmetrical because you'll  see  gah written down you'll be like oh i  know that that's train station